Die zwei Sprechstunden. Das heißt, das Chaosradio, es besteht eine große Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es sich bei dieser Ausgabe um die Folgenummer 183 bis 187 handelt.
Einigen wir uns mal auf 186.
Meinst du, ich fand 185, hätte ich aber irgendwie so ein bisschen runder gefunden, aber gut, was kann man machen. Also hier ist Chaosradio 186.
Ja, ist eine runde Zahl. Ja, per Definition.
Ach so, findest du per Definition. Na gut, also hier ist Chaosradio 186. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Im Studio sind Henrik und Simon. Hallo Henrik, hallo Simon. Guten Abend. Simon macht in Gebäudesicherheit. Henrik macht in Computersicherheit. Und das hier ist praktisch die zweite Ausgabe, ne die Fortsetzung der Sendung von vor genau einem, ne genau zwei Jahren, ist es jetzt 2003?
Wie hat der Hersteller damals reagiert?
Da muss ich kurz überlegen. Ich glaub, erst waren sie etwas, sie haben es auch irgendwie erst nicht mitgekriegt und dann gab es irgendwelche Pressemitteilungen von wegen, wir werden uns im Sinne unserer Kunden mit den maximalen rechtlichen Mitteln usw. Und dann...
Den Boden erschießen.
Jaja, genau, und dann hat sich jemand vom Chaos Computer Club mit denen getroffen. Ich war vorsichtshalber nicht da und dann verschwand die Pressemitteilung plötzlich. Und ansonsten ist der Hersteller auch sehr zugänglich, wie gesagt, wir haben das selber nie als Sicherheitsprodukt vermarktet und haben allen ihren Großkunden mit denen, also wenn da so ein richtig großer Kunde wie Microsoft bei denen eine Schulung macht, auch immer gesagt, ja keine Sicherheit, aber halt bei solchen kleineren Systemen. Da kommen wir wieder zu meiner Uni. Die hat nämlich, also das alte NEDAP-System ist dann letztes Jahr dann doch mal ausgeführt oder ist schon länger kaputt und ist letztes Jahr wohl komplett die Beine hochgerissen, also haben sie in der Not gedrungen das gleiche eingebaut, was die restliche Uni benutzt. Er stellt sich raus, ist Meifer Classic basierend. Und also was wir halt damals rausgefunden haben, war schon nicht sehr schmeichelhaft für das System, aber...
Naja, was heißt nicht schmeichelhaft? Also es war ja nie als Sicherheitssystem konzipiert.
Aber trotzdem...
Ist ja nicht das Problem des Herstellers.
Genau. Der Angriff, den Karsten und ein Kollege gefunden haben, dauerte glaube ich immer noch so was wie 12 Sekunden. Und auch nur, wenn man die richtigen Daten hat. Stellt sich raus, wir haben ja nicht alles veröffentlicht. Eine indische Forschungsgruppe an der Radbaut-Universität Nijmere hat sich das angeguckt. Die hatten das wohl auch schon mal vorher am Wickel und sind nicht weitergekommen, haben sich dann unsere Teilergebnisse angeguckt und haben den Rest, den wir nicht dazu gesagt haben, noch mal unabhängig von uns entdeckt und haben noch ein bisschen mehr gefunden. Die Karte hatte einen Implementierungsfehler. Normalerweise ist es halt so, dass auf der Karte ein Schlüssel ist und auch im Lesegerät ein Schlüssel. Und die Karte und das Lesegerät reden miteinander und dann wissen sie beide von sich gegenseitig, dass sie den Schlüssel kennen. Und das Lesegerät muss zuerst beweisen, dass sie den Schlüssel kennen, sonst sagt die Karte einfach gar nichts. Es gab einen Implementierungsfehler, als die Karte manchmal doch was gesagt hat. Und man davon dann schon wieder ein Stückchen auf den Schlüssel schließen konnte. Ja, also mit diesem neuen Angriff der Niederländer kann man den Algorithmus in, lass mich lügen, 90 Millisekunden, irgendwie sowas, also Bruchteile von Bruchteilen einer Sekunde brechen und das ist dann auch egal. Und mit dem Implementierungsfehler der Karte kann man das sogar tun, wenn man gar kein Lesegerät hat. Also kein echtes, man hat nur die Karte auf der Straße gefunden.
Die Türen deiner Uni stehen also sperngelweit offen im Prinzip?
Ja, ich hab dann also einfach mal eine meiner Karten, die ich legal habe, warum mich das so genervt hat, ich hab zwei Karten gekriegt. Ich hab eine für die Tür und eine mit einem Chip für den Computer. Und in der Chipkarte ist aber auch ein kontaktloser Chip drin, der ist bloß nicht bespielt und für die Tür freigeschaltet. Also hab ich zum einen mal angeguckt, wie das Ding funktioniert. Sie haben MyFair Classic, sie haben den gleichen Schlüssel für alle Karten. Und dann steht auf der Karte gespeichert, das ist im Datenbereich wirklich nur die aufgedruckte Nummer. Also hab ich das halt auf meiner Chipkarte für den Computer auch gemacht, hab den Schlüssel da eingestellt, die Nummer drauf kopiert und jetzt geht die halt auch.
Weiß deine Uni, dass dieses Problem besteht?
Ja genau, das ist dann der nächste Teil.
Oder erfahren Sie das gerade erst?
Ich hab dann mit dem Leiter der Rechnerbetriebsgruppe bei uns geredet und das Thema war ja neu eingebaut, noch nicht abgenommen usw. Und das ging dann auch zu seinem Lauf. Wie gesagt, da sind immer so mehrere Ebenen dazwischen. Die Firma, die die Schlösser herstellt, ist aus Thüringen, glaube ich. Hab den Namen schon wieder vergessen. Und ich hab natürlich erst mal gemeint, nee, nee, geht gar nicht. So, das ist völlig unmöglich so was. Das kann gar nicht sein. Dann hat der Rechnerbetriebsgruppenleiter mir einfach, sein Sohn arbeitet aber zufällig bei der Verwaltung, das macht sich sehr gut, hat mir einfach zwei Kartennummern aus der Verwaltung genannt. Die habe ich auf Karten geschrieben, die dann in der Verwaltung funktioniert haben. Das ging dann schon mal. Abgenommen haben sie das System trotzdem. Sie überlegen sich dann später nochmal, eine Erweiterung einzubauen, dass es nicht ganz so einfach ist, aber das Grundkonzept bleibt. Ich kann also jetzt jede Tür in der Uni öffnen.
Aber jeder, der das halbwegs verstanden hat, was du gerade erzählt hast, kann auch jede Tür der Uni öffnen.
Ja, wenn ihr die richtige Kartennummer kennt. Notfalls probiert man sie halt durch. Die sind halt der Reihe nach...
Oder man klaut sich eine.
Ja, das wäre ja einfacher. Die sind zum Glück ja aufgedruckt. Man braucht bloß die aufgedruckte Nummer wissen.
Das mit dem Klauen ist ja gerade der Punkt der elektronischen Systeme. Weil die geklaute Karte wird ja dann gemeldet und wird ja dann gesperrt. Also die wird ja aus der Zutrittsberechtigungsliste einfach entfernt. Das ist ja eigentlich der Grund oder einer der Hauptgründe, warum man sich so ein System anschafft.
Genau, deswegen ist es immer schöner, wenn man eine Karte nicht klauen muss, sondern irgendwie anders benutzen kann.
Sondern die, das Schuldirektors einmal ausliest, ohne dass der es mitbekommt.
Genau, wenn man dann ein System hat, was nach Auslesen eine Kopie ermöglicht und nicht nur ordentliche Systeme erlauben, das halt nicht. Da kommen wir aber ganz spät dazu, glaube ich.
Was ich ja jetzt noch gerne wüsste, also wenn die Nummer mit War Games und diesem Tape, wenn die funktioniert, also wenn das tatsächlich geht, was aus den ganzen Agentenfilmen funktioniert denn dann sonst noch? Also da gibt's ja so, weiß ich nicht, also das Absurdeste, was ich mal gesehen hab, das war allerdings in einer Comedy, da hat jemand in ein Röhrchen gehaucht, woraufhin, also Atemkontroll gesteuert, die Tür aufgegangen ist. Das gibt's. Das gibt's? Das war Community, nichts, was in Community hier gezeigt wird, gibt's.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, das hat neulich mal, zumindest experimentell gab es solche Systeme. Ja, alles Mögliche. Vieles ist grober Unfug, manches nicht. Ein sehr schöner Film ist zum Beispiel Sneakers, die lautlosen. Da geht es auch um irgendwie so eine schwarze Box, was aus filmtechnischer Sicht ja einfach bloß so das Teil ist, was man haben muss. Ja klar. Was aber, wenn man halt drauf guckt, ja, das ist offensichtlich irgendein System, irgendein Ding, was RSA faktorisiert, worauf halt die meisten asymmetrischen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen basieren. Und wenn es sowas gäbe, wäre es, es ist nicht, mathematisch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es das gibt leider. Und wenn es sowas gäbe, wäre es halt was tolles. Und solche Dinge gibt es halt in vielen Filmen. Ich glaube, bei dem neuen James Bond, der so komisch aussieht, haben sie auch damit geworben, dass alle Dinge, die er benutzt, in der Realität existieren, diese ganzen Handys und der ganze Kram, das mit dem SIM-Karte kopieren ist nicht ganz so einfach, aber ging früher prinzipiell auch.
Wie hat er das denn gemacht, SIM-Karte kopieren? Hat er die alte überhaupt rausgenommen?
Ja, ich glaube, er hat sie in ein Gerät gesteckt und hat halt ein Handy, was genauso funktioniert. Ich habe gerade erst auf einem Kongressenvortrag gehört, dass es tatsächlich nicht ganz so abwegig ist, dass also, wenn man es tatsächlich hinkriegen kann, ein Handy zweimal einzubuchen unter Umständen und dann Dinge mitkriegt. Aber das war mehr so auf Funk-Ebene, also da braucht man dann die SIM-Karte gegebenenfalls nicht mal für. Und früher konnte man wohl auch SIM-Karten kopieren, das haben sie wohl mittlerweile größtenteils gefixt, da waren also irgendwelche Probleme mit den SIM-Karten.
Aber wo wir gerade bei Abschweifen und Filmen und Aufsperrtechniken waren, also ein absoluter Filmklassiker sind ja diese Kreditcheck-Karten, mit denen man einfach die Tür aufmacht.
Ja, genau.
Das ist total klasse, wenn wir mal so zu Notöffnungen kommen und in der Tür schon so zwei abgebrochene Karten stecken.
Das ist nicht wahr, oder? Das passiert wirklich?
Ja, manchmal auch drei oder vier. Oder völlig zerstörte Personalausweise.
Ja, meiner hat auch leichte Dellen.
Der Personalausweis geht schon, also der alte zumindest, geht schon in die richtige Richtung. Der Hintergrund ist, dass diese Karten einfach viel zu starr sind und nicht um die Ecke des Türfalzes kommen und dann einfach abbrechen.
Ja, aber dann nimmt man doch eine aufgeschnittene Petflasche, oder nicht? Zum Beispiel. Also das weiß ja sogar ich.
Also ich hatte das Problem auch schon mal und ich hatte dann tatsächlich, also mein Personalausweis hat leichte Dellen davon getragen. Mein Problem war nämlich, dass das Loch, in das die Falle fällt, einfach viel zu groß war, dass der Personalausweis drin verschwunden. Das ging dann halt, die erwünschte Hebelwirkung war da nicht da. Ein Freund von mir kam dann einfach vorbei mit so einer Plastedingst und dann war die Tür auch in 30 Sekunden auf ihm.
Ja, ich hab mich mal ausgesperrt. Ja, genau. Da hab ich dann gesehen, also er hat das dann mit so einem komischen Metallteil gemacht und ich dachte, okay, Petflasche aufschneiden, müsste ungefähr denselben Effekt haben.
Also ich hab mir das dann auch irgendwann mal im Köln Kongress mitgenommen. Es gibt solche Öffnungskarten, in denen einfach so Plaste ist mit Metaflon-Beschichtung, dass es auch rutscht und...
Gibt es da eigentlich Fachgeschäfte für, in die man, ich mein, so jemand wie du, der muss doch irgendwo auch einen Großhandel haben, wo...
Richtig, da gibt's Firmen, die sich auf Aufsperrwerkzeug spezialisiert haben. In der Regel verkaufen die Leute nur gegen einen Gewerbeschein. Also man muss halt vorzeigen, dass man ein Gewerbe dafür hat. So ein Gewerbeschein kostet 25 Euro und man kann die Werbe auch gleich wieder abmelden. Dann sieht man ja, mir Werbeschein ja erstmal nicht an. Aber es gibt ja eigentlich eine leichte Kontrolle, aber ich würde auch nicht für jeden Kollegen meine Hand ins Feuer legen, dass er es nicht einfach so weiterverkauft.
Würde man das merken? Nee, das würde niemand merken. Wenn du zwei Dinge im Großhandel kaufst und mir eins verscheuerst, krieg ich ja keiner mit.
Ja, es kann ja auch kaputt sein, oder für einen anderen Mitarbeiter. Ja, kann ja auch ganz trivial sein, dir wird das Auto mit dem Werkzeug geklaut. Also bei uns ist so weit über Nacht nie im Auto, aber kann passieren.
Zurück zur Elektronik.
Machen wir die Klammer wieder zu. Elektronik, genau, nicht Plaste. Also manchmal auch vor allen Dingen Plaste.
Plaste-Elektronik.
Ja, das ist eher bei E-Books der nächste große Renner und Handys, dass man die Displays so aus Plaste macht, damit die nicht aus Glas sind und gleich springen, wenn man sie von der Seite schief anguckt. Es gibt da sehr schöne Demonstrationsvideos, wie jemand so ein Display nimmt und mit dem Hammer draufhaut.
Ah cool, ich kenn das halt von normalen Gehäuse. Ein Freund von mir hat dieses Nokia, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es heißt, der knackt damit immer Nüsse. Allerdings mit der Rückseite. Das sieht sehr spektakulär aus. Das ist halt Polycarbonat. Kannst du halt mitmachen, was du willst. Der arbeitet halt auch bei Nokia und macht dann halt immer einen auf die Kose. Ja, ihr mit euren scheiß iPhones, hast mal eine Walnuss. Klatsch, klatsch, klatsch. Und dann ist halt die Nuss auf. Sehr schön eigentlich.
Also ist es nicht so, als ob ich nicht auch schon eine Flasche mit meinem Telefon offen macht hätte, aber die sehen dann danach auch meistens ziemlich ungünstig aus.
Also da ist halt nichts dran. Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich hab auch schon den Verdacht gehabt, dass der vielleicht irgendwie so einen super geheimen Geheimprototypen hat, um uns alle zu beeindrucken, damit wir dieses scheiß Telefon kaufen. Oh, das war ein Filmhandy. Genau. Aber ich hab damit auch fotografiert. Konnte das überhaupt fotografieren? Das hat sogar so einen ganz creepy Bildstabilisator gehabt. Der meinte, lass mich dir das mal zeigen. Das hier ist die, ich hab einen Kasten Bier drin Variante. Und hat dann das Handy genommen, hat mit dem Ding so hin und her gewackelt, die ganze Zeit und dann einfach auf einen Auslöser gedrückt. Und das Ding hat es geschafft, aus diesem Gewackel ein scharfes Bild zu errechnen. Ich war sehr beeindruckt.
Das ist die Variante, wo Nokia neulich auf die Schnauze geflogen ist, weil sie in der Reflektion einfach, sie haben halt den Bildstabilisator beworben und fuhren halt an einem Geschäft vorbei und in der Reflektion sah man dann halt den Wagen mit dem Stativ von der Kamera.
Na aber das hat also, an dem Handy hat das ganz gut funktioniert. Es ist dann nur so ein komisches Betriebssystem drauf.
Ja.
Aber um mal wieder in den Bogen zu schlagen, es gibt ja auch Handys, mit denen man Türen öffnen kann.
Ja, es gibt auch Leute, die so was machen.
James Bond hatte so eins, mit Elektroschocker drin auch gleichzeitig.
Ja, es gibt da ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Es gibt Handys, denen ein Transponder integriert ist. Es gibt auch Handys.
Seit fünf Jahren das neue Schlagwort NFC.
Niervier Communications. Hab sogar ich schon von gehört, Cis.
Ja, ja, das kommt seit fünf Jahren, nächstes Jahr.
Achso, das ist sozusagen der Fusionsreaktor.
Also die Japaner haben es halt schon, in Europa streiten sich vor allen Dingen, wie das mit der Sicherheit ist. Also der große Trick, dieser Transponder macht halt im Wesentlichen genau das gleiche, wie so eine Karte, so eine kontaktlose Karte. Und damit der aber auch so sicher ist wie eine kontaktlose Karte mit einem Sicherheitschip, muss halt noch ein Sicherheitschip irgendwo im Handy sein. Und so streiten sie sich. Nokia hat im Wesentlichen eine kontaktlose Karte eingelötet. Also ein ganz normales, so ein ganz normaler Chip. Und hat dann halt die Schlüssel bei Nokia. Das finden jetzt die Telekom Operators, die die Mobilfunk-Netzbetreiber nicht so toll, weil ja die hätten ja also wer den Chip kontrolliert, kontrolliert halt wer den benutzen darf und von wem er Geld dafür kriegen kann, dass er den Chip benutzt. Deswegen finden die Mobilfunkbetreiber das nicht toll, dass der Handyhersteller das hat. Umgekehrt finden die Handyhersteller das nicht toll, wenn die Mobilfunk-Schreiber das haben. Deswegen, es gibt jetzt neuerdings einen Standard, dass man genau das Gleiche mit der SIM-Karte macht, dass also der ganze Kram mit dem Kontaktlostings in der SIM-Karte drin ist. Das soll so demnächst mal eventuell vielleicht kommen. Ich glaube, das neue Google-Telefon hat das wohl schon, aber ob es jemand benutzt, ist unklar.
Gibt es überhaupt einen Anwendungsfall dafür? Also einen in der Realität?
Ja, beim Bahnfahren.
Ja, beim Bahnfahren. Aber die haben ja dann auch wieder ein System, womit das nicht geht. Oder?
Inwiefern nicht geht?
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Aber normalerweise ist es so, dass alle irgendwas in den Handys haben, was theoretisch total geil ist. Und dann denkt sich die S-Bahn was aus, womit das nicht funktioniert. Weil die irgendein eigenes System haben wollen. Das ist eigentlich das, was ich erwarte, wenn ich so, wenn ich so, dein Handy kann jetzt auch Fahrscheine, aber nur in London.
Also die sind halt wirklich, dieses NFC ist halt kein eigentlicher neuer Standard. Das ist mehr so, ja wir gucken uns mal an, was wir haben, tun noch drei Dinge dazu und nennen das NFC. NFC ist kein wohl definierter Begriff. Das sind ganz viele verschiedene Dinge. Die meisten davon rückwärts kompatibel mit existierenden RFID-Systemen.
Also auf dem Level der Uni dann.
Genau, das ist also so ein MyFair Classic Tag, der einfach drin ist und das ist dann auch andere Dinge wie Desfire Karten im Prinzip auch machen kann. Da kommen wir dann später noch mal zu, was die können. Und dann kommt es halt nur noch darauf an, dass du Zugriff auf die richtige Stelle hast, die richtigen Dinge an der richtigen Stelle installieren zu können. Da streitet man sich dann halt wieder. Das ist jetzt der Betriebssystemhersteller, der Mobilfunkbetreiber, der Handyhersteller, der Nutzer vielleicht sogar. Also dem Nutzer kann man nicht vertrauen, deswegen gar nicht. Und wer denn jetzt den Goldesel bedienen darf.
Aber eigentlich will sich der Nutzer ja nur selber vertrauen.
Also bei diesem alten Nokia-System konnte man bei Nokia einfach fragen und konnte dann halt von denen den Schlüssel kriegen. Dann haben die aber in ihrer Datenbank das Handy als unvertrauenswürdig markiert und...
Super, dann geht die Tür nicht auf.
Ja, dann kannst du halt später keine Anwendungen installieren, die ein vertrauenswürdiges Handy braucht.
Genau.
Aber es gibt durchaus auch Handy-Türöffnungsmechanismen, die auf älteren Technologien beruhen, Bluetooth oder ganz banal über einen Webbrowser. Also man ruft einfach eine Internetseite auf, wo ein Knopf drauf ist, jetzt aufmachen. Da gibt es Leute, die damit Alarmanlagen steuern.
In meinem Kopf schreit die ganze Zeit ein Marktschreier, Smart Home, Smart Home, das haben sie auch.
Oder Alarmanlagen, die teilweise über eine Webseite gesteuert werden, wo nicht mal diese SSL-Verschlüsselung, wie man sie von der Bank kennt, oder von so halbwegs vertrauenserweckenden Seiten. Aber eine Alarmanlage ein- und ausschalten, ohne Verschlüsselung, einfach nur der Klartext mit Passwort und allem Drum und Dran durch die Luft, perfekt.
Also teilweise ist es dann auch über das Internet oder wenigstens dann auch Short-Range oder über Funk.
Über das Internet.
Viele dieser Systeme schreiben sich dann die Cloud auf die Fahnen und da sind dann die Hersteller mal ganz glücklich, weil sie dann quasi die Systeme, die bei dir in der Tür sind oder bei dir zu Hause, Smart Home, an den Server beim Hersteller binden und das macht dann so kundenbindungstechnisch.
Es ist egal, wie sicher es ist, du kannst es mit deinem Smartphone bedienen und das ist cool.
Genau. Also in Amerika ist das gerade, da habe ich gerade irgendwelche Start-ups und Kick-Start und der ganze Kram und ja, wir machen das dann in der Cloud und das ist dann toll.
Ja Amerika zählt nicht, die haben auch auf dem mechanischen Markt nichts zu bieten.
Ja gut, ich glaube da gehen wir mal schnell durch, dann kommen wir nämlich zu dem großen Spaß in Amerika.
Das Gesicht hätte ich gerne fotografiert gerade.
Ja, aus unserer Sicht ist Amerika natürlich in vielen Stellen ein Entwicklungsland, was so Infrastruktur angeht, das Stromstecker können sie auch nicht.
Ja, also das erzählt auch jeder, der in Amerika war, also selbst, also ja, alle Handwerker, die so in meinem Bekanntenkreis sind, die mal in Amerika Urlaub gemacht haben, egal was für ein Handwerk es ist, dass sie ausüben, kommen zurück und sagen, das ist schlimmer als im Osten.
Handwerker, das Backhandwerk soll ja auch zu kurz kommen.
Ist alles, ich sag ja alles.
Ich glaube, das Juristenhandwerk ist da ganz gut vertreten. Ja, na gut, also wir waren bei MyFair Classic. Da gibt es halt alle möglichen Dinge, alles möglich kaputt. Man kann sich da noch viel mehr machen. Die Niederländer waren zum Beispiel, als wir das aufgemacht haben, gerade dabei ein landesweites System für öffentlichen Personen nachverkehrt darauf basierend einzuführen. Das hat sich dann auch so ein bisschen verzögert.
Da wäre die Idee gewesen, meine Kartennummer löst einen Ticketkauf aus.
Na, da ist dann also auf den MyFair Classic Karten, da sind wir jetzt wirklich schon bei intelligenteren Karten, auf den Karten was speichern kann. Da ist dann nicht mehr nur eine Kartennummer, sondern Speicher und der MyFair-Teil, deswegen heißt es Micron Fair System, daher kommt der Name. Das MyFair hat von Anfang an so eine Art elektronische Geldbörse, wo es halt Betrag auf der Karte gespeichert gibt und dann einfach Befehle gibt. Betrag incrementieren, Betrag dekrementieren und man dann die beiden Befehle an unterschiedliche Berechtigungen knüpfen kann.
Ist da dann wenigstens, also ist mein Geld dann wenigstens halbwegs oder sogar sehr vernünftig verschlüsselt?
Wie gesagt, sobald du auf die Karten zugreifen kannst, hat der Verteidiger verloren. Bei diesem ganzen System, also MyFair wird zum Beispiel immer noch eingesetzt in Berlin in der Mensa-Karte, in ganz vielen Mensa-Karten und anderen Uni-Karten, da ist dann einfach ein Schattenkonto, das also auf der anderen, irgendwo eine Datenbank im Hintergrund arbeitet, die weiß, wie viel Geld noch auf deiner Karte ist. Das ist dann zum Schutz des Kartensystembetreibers, nicht zu deinem Schutz. Du kannst halt nicht mehr Geld ausgeben, als du draufgeladen hast. Hoffentlich manchmal vielleicht.
Ihr hört Chaosradio 186 auf Fritz. Henrik referiert über elektronische Schließsysteme. Simon macht Einwürfe und ich wundere mich. Und nach den Nachrichten geht's weiter. Chaosradio 186 ist hier, glauben wir jedenfalls, dass Chaosradio 186 ist. Also wir haben demokratisch beschließen lassen, dass hier Chaosradio 186 ist.
Sehr schön.
Sehr schön haben wir das beschließen lassen. Hendrik hat gesagt, sehr schön, Simon ist auch im Studio und ich bin Holger. Es geht um elektronische Schließsysteme.
Wo waren wir? Genau, wir waren jetzt so bei besseren Karten, die nicht nur eine einfache Nummer senden, sondern halt noch irgendwas mehr können. Das allerdings regelmeistens trotzdem kaputt ist. Also Mifare Klassiker gesagt sind wir neuerdings bei, wenn man Lesegerät und Karte abhört, 90 Millisekunden zum brechen, wenn man nur die Karte in der Hand hat, so zwei Minuten, da ist das Lesegerät dann tatsächlich relativ günstig. Es gibt da so ein Projekt, das sich mit, wir waren bei NFC mal kurz, es gab eine Firma, die sich da, die da so was wie Anschub leisten wollte und einen sogenannten Touch Attack verkauft hat. Das war also ein NFC-Lesegerät mit ganz vielen Text, die man dann auf seinen Teddy-Bear kleben kann und dann gibt es irgendwie ein Programmierumgebung, wenn man seinen Teddy-Bear an das Lesegerät hält, passiert irgendwas Tolles. Aber das Lesegerät gibt es, also es war halt irgendwie so 30 Euro das Paket und das reicht völlig aus und gerade für dieses Lesegerät sind die meisten Dinge entwickelt worden. Also so ein Touch Attack hat und eine Wi-Fi Classic-Karte draufliest, sich die richtige Software aus dem Internet nimmt, dann hat man halt in ungefähr zwei Minuten den Schlüssel. Wenn man den Schlüssel hat, kann man halt auf der Karte rumschreiben oder eine neue Karte mit dem gleichen Schlüssel beschreiben und so weiter und so fort. Was noch eine kleine Hürde ist, ist, dass alle Karten eine eindeutige Seriennummer haben. Das ist jetzt aus datenschutztechnischer Sicht nicht so gut, weil die halt immer frei abrufbar ist, aber macht halt die Sicherheit an der Stelle besser, weil sie zumindest auf normalen Karten nicht änderbar ist. Du kannst halt entweder dann ein teures Gerät nehmen, wie den Proxmark oder das USRP und so tun, als wärst du eine Karte, aber du kannst halt nicht so eine 1-Euro-Karte nehmen und die Seriennummer ändern. Es gibt allerdings, wie ich weiß, in Asien irgendwo, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo genau, ich glaube im Proxmark-Sourcecode ist da ein Hinweis, gibt es jemanden, der MyFair Classic Karten verkauft für, ich glaube, 30 Dollar das Stück oder so, wo man die Seriennummer ändern kann. Damit ist dann das auch gegessen und es gibt halt viele Systeme, erstaunlich viele Systeme, die nur die Seriennummer benutzen, auch wenn die Karte mehr könnte. Ich erinnere zum Beispiel, dass die neuen Schlösser im Jakob, Jakob und Wilhelm, so heißen die noch bestimmt, jedenfalls im Grimm-Zentrum der Humboldt-Universität in Berlin haben so was. Die haben halt an der Bibliothek vorm Eingang so Schließfächer und wenn man da seine Sachen einschließen will, kann man das mit seiner Mensa-Karte machen, es benutzt aber von der Mensa-Karte nur die Seriennummer. Und das hat sich auch mal jemand an der Uni angeguckt und hat festgestellt, nutzt nur die Seriennummer und wenn man halt die Seriennummer fälschen kann, dann kann man die Schlösser auch öffnen. Ein weiteres System, was ungefähr aus der gleichen Zeit wie MyFair Classic stammt, wäre Logic, Logic Prime genauer gesagt. Man muss immer bei diesen Dingen darauf achten. MyFair, da sag ich auch immer MyFair Classic, MyFair ist nur so der Markenname des ganzen Systems. Da hat sich NXP, die Firma, das hergestellt hat, auch so ein Ei gelegt. Die Karte, die hieß ursprünglich MyFair. Da haben sie ganz viele andere Produkte gebaut, die sie einfach auch MyFair nennen. MyFair Ultralight hat zum Beispiel technisch mit MyFair Classic nichts zu tun. Oder MyFair Deathfire. Und dann haben wir halt 2006, 2007 MyFair Classic kaputt gemacht. In der Presse stand aber immer nur MyFair ist kaputt. Schade eigentlich. Deswegen drauf achten. Bei Ledgic ist es genauso. Ledgic ist eine andere Firma aus der Schweiz diesmal. Die haben auch zwei Produkte. Das ältere ist Ledgic Prime. Ist ungefähr aus der gleichen Zeit und gleichen Bude wie MyFair Classic damals. Hatte noch so ein Hauch der Exklusivität, ein Hauch des Luxus. Ist irgendwie teuer und muss was Besonderes und ist bestimmt doll sicher. Ledgic hat sich da auch sehr...
Haben die das als Sicherheitsding verkauft?
Ledgic gehört nämlich mittlerweile zu CABA und die kommen mehr aus dem Bereich der mechanischen Schließsysteme, wo es dann auch einen Schließplan gibt und irgendeine hierarchische Gruppenschließung und so ein Kram und sowas Ähnliches hat Ledgic Prime dann auf seinen Karten gebaut. Sie nennen das genetischer Code. Genetisch klingt immer super. Ja, macht sich in der Werbung ganz großartig.
Und Doppel Helix kann man super Logos auch bauen.
Ja, ja, in der internen Doku nennen sie es einfach Stamp, was dann einfacher ist. Es ist einfach bloß eine Byte-Folge. So 1 bis 16, glaube ich, Byte. 16 klingt zu viel, sagen wir mal 10 oder 12. 12 klingt besser. So 1 bis mehrere Byte. Und man kann dann halt Berechtigungen zum Beschreiben der Karten vergeben, wenn basierend auf diesem Byte-String, auf einem Präfix von diesem Stamp. Man kann also sagen, wir haben halt irgendwie einen großen Konzern, großer Konzern mit mehreren Niederlassungen und hat einen großen Konzern mit mehreren Landesteilen. Dann kann man halt sagen, Deutschland kriegt den einen Anfang, Frankreich den anderen, Niederlande den nächsten. Dann kann man halt innerhalb Deutschlands, macht man halt die Byte-Folge einfach länger und tut einfach hinten noch ein bisschen was dran. Und dann kann man halt innerhalb Deutschlands aufteilen nach Berlin, Bonn, Frankfurt und so weiter. Und innerhalb Berlin, Bonn, Frankfurt aufteilen nach und so weiter und so fort. Und es geht dann immer von oben nach unten, dass jeder, der auf einer höheren Ebene setzt, Karten für eine niedrigere Ebene ausgeben kann. Das ist halt so ähnlich gebaut, wie das dann bei Schließsystem, Schließplänen gedacht ist. Ich stelle es sich raus, die gesamte Sicherheit, die da drin ist, wird im Lesengerät implementiert. Sie haben halt wieder so ein proprietäres System, wo sie keinem gesagt haben, wie es funktioniert. Ich habe es mir dann angeguckt. Starbuck und Karsten haben den Algorithmus rausgefunden. Ich sage jetzt nicht mal Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus. Das hat mir mein Kryptografie-Professor damals noch so schön formuliert. Eine Verschlüsselung ist es nur, wenn es einen Schlüssel hat. Da war ich bei Lejcik Prime etwas enttäuscht. Die haben zwar einen Algorithmus, der so ähnlich aussieht wie in der Stromschiffre, aber der hat keinen Schlüsseleingang. Da geht bloß eine Zahl rein, die aber vorher im Klartext übertragen wird. Also so eine Art Zufallszahl, so eine Art Nons. Das haben viele andere Systeme auch. Nennen ist dann aber extra nicht Verschlüsselung und Magic Prime hat halt sonst nichts. Wenn man halt weiß, wie es funktioniert, dann kann man Magic Prime Karten lesen und Lesegeräte bauen und Magic Prime Karten beschreiben. Denn es stellt sich raus, ist auf den Karten dieser ganze Stemm, dieser genetische Code, dieser Präfixmatch, der ganze hierarchische Kram ist nicht auf den Karten implementiert, sondern im Lesegerät. Wenn man also ein eigenes Lesegerät baut, kann man Karten beliebig verhunzen, was auch immer man möchte. Und ich kann sogar Karten, ich kann auch einen Emulator bauen, das habe ich auch gemacht, in der dann so tut, als wäre eine Karte auf der bliebige Dinge stehen, unter anderem zum Beispiel die Berechtigung für ein Lesegerät, auf Karten zu schreiben. Das hat Lechik nämlich auch gemacht, dass sie diese Berechtigung auf Karten verteilen. Das finden sie dann auch ganz toll, dass man die in Safe legen kann und so wie Schlüsselkarten im normalen Schließsystem. Dass man also nur, wenn man diese Schlüsselkarte hat, neue Schlüssel herstellen kann. Aber ich kann halt einfach solche Schlüsselkarten auch selber herstellen und dann halt ein normales, offizielles Lesegerät nehmen und damit beliebige Dinge tun. Lechik Prime ist genauso und noch viel mehr kaputt als MyFair Classic. Das war dann auch so ein bisschen...
Wenn ich meine Bude ordentlich verschließen will, mit so einem elektromagnetischen System oder einem elektronischen Schließsystem, gibt es irgendeine Stelle, zu der ich hingehen kann und sagen kann, erklären Sie mir jetzt mal, welches davon tatsächlich sicher ist? Oder bin ich darauf angewiesen, zufälligerweise mal so ein Chaosradio zu hören und dich eine Mail schicken zu können?
Für Privatanwender weiß ich da tatsächlich nichts. Ich komme darauf später noch mal zurück, aber wir haben die Firma, für die ich arbeite...
Das gibt es mir viel später, denk mal auf die Uhr.
Ja, die Firma, die ich arbeite, wir haben einen White Paper geschrieben, wo wir dann mal Best Practices for Access Control, wo wir einfach mal hingeschrieben haben, wie man sich das so vorstellt. Und die wichtigsten Punkte sind halt, keine proprietären Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen nehmen und irgendwie darauf achten, also jede Karte soll einen anderen Schlüssel haben und darauf achten, was passiert, wenn man Karten verliert und wenn man Schlösser verliert, in Anführungszeichen, also die Schlüssel bekannt werden. Und dann halt AIS oder Triple Desk nehmen, wie sich herausstellt, es gibt tatsächlich eine Karte der Firma NXP, Mifare, Deathfire, EV1 neuerdings, die sowas kann und wenn man das richtig benutzt, dann hat man schon mal keine Probleme mehr auf der Verschlüsselungsseite, keine Probleme mehr auf der Implementierungsseite, zumindest bei der EV1, die ältere ist tatsächlich schon gebrochen. Dann kann man halt nur noch in Anführungszeichen das Schlüsselmanagement verhauen, was dann halt relativ häufig passiert.
Fehler, da reiße ich.
Ja, halt irgendwie für alle Karten den gleichen Schlüssel nehmen und dann geht ein und das dann.
Das ist der Idiot, der vor dem Computer sitzt.
Ja, genau. Naja, der Idiot, der vor dem Computer sitzt, in dem das System programmiert wird. Also der Entwickler des Systems. Selbst die Systeme, wie sie Firmen benutzen, haben sowas in der Regel nicht. Also als wir das zwei Papers geschrieben haben, kamen die Firmen einfach, kamen die Firmen da plötzlich und sagten, ja wir finden keinen Anbieter, der das anbietet, wach uns das doch mal. Dann haben wir halt mit solchen Firmen, die solche Systeme herstellen, die also die Dinge zum Einbauen in die Tür herstellen, zusammengearbeitet und denen mal beigebracht, erklärt, wie man das implementieren würde, was wir uns vorgestellt haben. Sodass es jetzt also wirklich ein paar größere Firmen gibt, die ein unserer Meinung nach sicheres System einsetzen.
Es ist also nicht alles verloren. Darum geht es mir jetzt so ein bisschen.
Also ein Punkt, den ich noch kurz einschieben möchte, weil wir dann nämlich auf Vigern zu sprechen kommen. Es gibt nämlich noch, noch bevor wir bei Deathfire sind, gibt es ein System namens, gibt es eine Firma namens HID, die auch Karten herstellen. Das ältere System, wie bei Logic und bei MyFair Classic, gibt es immer irgendwie ein altes und neues System. Bei Logic ist das alte Logic Prime, das neue Logic Advanced. Bei HID ist das alte System HID Prox und das neue System HID iClass. Das alte System ist wieder so ein ID-basiertes, was man halt vergessen kann. Das neue System verwendet tatsächlich Triple Desk und Desk und Triple Desk. So wie ich gesagt habe, das braucht man. Das ist schon mal eine notwendige Voraussetzung dafür, dass es sicher ist. Wie gesagt, kann man es immer noch auf andere Ebene verhauen. Und zwar verwendet HID in der Standardeinstellung den gleichen Schlüssel für alle Karten, die sie herstellen weltweit. Also den gleichen Master Schlüssel. Wenn man also herausgefunden hat, wie das funktioniert und den Schlüssel hat, dann kann man also auch HID Karten herstellen. Ich hör dir iClass Karten. Sie haben dann halt noch für besonders vielzahlende Kunden andere Programme, wo sie dann Karten herstellen, wo man seinen eigenen Schlüssel einstellen kann. Aber das machen halt nicht wirklich viele Firmen. Das ist auch aufwendig und was passiert, wenn man den Master Schlüssel verliert? Das ist natürlich, wenn man seinem Chef das erklären will, immer so ein wichtiges Problem. Dem ist der Teil, dass die Tür nicht aufgeht, wenn ein Angreifer davor steht, gerade nicht so wichtig, ist wesentlich wichtiger. Das hab ich auch bei den anderen Firmen gelernt. Dass die Tür aufgeht, wenn der CEO davor steht mit seiner Karte. Das hab ich auch irgendwie als Feedback bei der einen Firma gehabt, dass der Mensch von der Sicherheit, der die Karten herstellt, halt wohl irgendwann mal, da gab es irgendwie ein Problem und der hat halt eine Karte hergestellt und dem Vorstandsvorsitzenden gegeben und die ging dann nicht. Und das macht man halt nur einmal in seiner Berufslaufbahn. Und beim zweiten Mal ist dann, dann war es das dann.
Das ist ein psychologisches Ding wahrscheinlich auch, wenn ich hier antanze, gehen alle Türen automatisch auf.
Genau. Und deswegen ist man auf dieser Ebene sehr bedacht, ein System zu wählen, was halt dann auch wirklich aufgeht. Halt wie gesagt, der andere Fall ist dann weniger wichtig. Etadier hat vor allen Dingen noch den lustigen Teil von dem, was sie auf den Karten speichern. Also sie haben halt so irgendwie Verschlüsselung und Authentisierung und zwar alle den gleichen Schlüssel, aber ist schon mal auf der luftigen Stelle ein bisschen verschlüsselt. Und dann übertragen sie eine Nummer. Und zwar geht das darauf zurück, dass es ein amerikanisches System ist. Und in Amerika gibt es aus historischen Gründen fast, also eigentlich überall, Vigand-Verkabelung. Vigand ist so ein Physiker.
Ich weise darauf hin, dass im Skript zur Sendung steht, Vigand, muhaha.
Ja genau. Also Vigand ist halt ein sehr lustiges 70er-Jahre Technologie. Das war halt so das erste, was man damals hatte für kontaktlos. Vigand ist ein Physiker, der hat einen Effekt gefunden an magnetischen Drähten, den dann der Vigand-Effekt heißt. Ich weiß nicht, ist ein Amerikaner, kann auch weigend sein, aber ich sag jetzt Vigand. Und der Effekt führt dazu, dass wenn man versucht, die umzumagnetisieren, dass da irgendwie so eine Kaskadenwirkung gibt, und es plötzlich anfängt ganz, also erst passiert gar nichts, sondern passiert plötzlich was, was man dann wieder sehr leicht empfangen kann. Deswegen war das damals so beliebt. Und so eine Vigan-Karte ist im Wesentlichen so ähnlich wie ein Barcode. Also es gibt da so zwei Spuren mit ganz vielen Spalten. Und dann ist entweder in der, die Spuren sind 0 und 1, und dann ist halt entweder in der Nullspalte oder in der Einspalte was drin. Und das zieht man dann durch, durch dieses magnetische Wechselfeld. Und wenn halt in der Nullspalte was drin ist, dann passiert da was, und wenn in der Einspalte was drin ist, passiert da was. Und dann hat man halt 26 Bit gespeichert, kontaktlos in den 70er Jahren, war man total glücklich. Ja, also es ist halt wieder nur so ein ID-basiertes System, vor allen Dingen mit einer sehr kurzen ID. Das zu wiegern gehört auch ein Standard, wie man diese 26 Bit aufteilt in irgendwie so und so viel Bit Housecode und so und so viel Bit Kartencode und dann auch Paritätsbits dazutut. Und dann gibt es noch eine Verkabelung durch dieses Format, durch dieses Kartenlayout hat man halt sofort nur 0 und 1 Bits. Man hat also nicht irgendwie ein Bit, was 0 oder 1 sein kann, sondern man hat einfach Spitzen bei 0 oder bei 1. Deswegen gibt es drei Kabel. Es gibt ein Massekabel, ein 1 Kabel und ein 0 Kabel. Und dann laufen halt hintereinander entweder auf dem 0 oder 1 Kabel Impulse lang. Und das ist die Standard-Vigand-Verkabelung, die auch heute noch in den USA der Hauptstandard ist für alles Mögliche. Jedes Alarmsystem, jedes Tür-Controller, jedes Türsteuerungssystem hat einen Vigand-Eingang. Und auch diese HID-Karten basieren darauf. Also diese HID-Karten haben halt auf ihnen drauf gespeichert eine Nummer. Und selbst dieser tolle, also der tollste HID-Leser mit Biometrie und Verschlüsselung und eigenem Schlüssel und allem drum und dran, gibt dann am Ende auf Wunsch nur noch einfach eine Vigand-ID aus. Da hat HID dann noch deswegen Mojaha. HID hat das natürlich sicher in Anführungszeichen gemacht. HID hat nämlich nicht nur das Standard-Vigand-Format mit 26 Bit, sondern sie haben eigene Formate definiert mit 35 Bit. Und das verkaufen sie einem dann als Sicherheitsfeature, weil ja keiner weiß, wie das Format aussieht. Also mit Format ist gemeint diese Aufteilung, welche der Bit sind jetzt der House-Code und welche sind der Karten-Code. Da kann man ja, wenn man so eine Anzahl von Bits hat, das irgendwie anders aufteilen. Da müssen ja nicht hintereinander stehen.
Ja, aber kann ich denn nicht, wenn ich einfach eine Handvoll Karten habe, das eher halten? Also wenn das sogar schon mir auffällt, dass man das irgendwie...
Ja, nee.
Dann muss das Dir doch erst recht auffallen und vor allen Dingen gelingen.
Ja, ja. In der Broschüre beschreiben Sie das trotzdem als Sicherheitsfeature, dass halt nicht jeder solche Karten herstellen kann, weil er halt nicht weiß, in Anführungszeichen, wie das Ding funktioniert. Es ist natürlich ein Sicherheitsfeature, aber es ist vor allen Dingen ein Sicherheitsfeature, um sich vor Konkurrenz zu schützen, weil halt wie gesagt nicht jeder einfach so die Karten herstellen kann, es sei denn es geht halt mit krimineller Energie dran. Und dann haben sie glaube ich sogar noch, also 35 Bit ist so das Nonplusultra bei HID. Sie haben aber glaube ich noch so längere Quotes mit 40 Bit. Aber wie gesagt, es ist alles einfach bloß eine Nummer, die gesendet wird und das dann auch egal ist. Es gab in Amerika jemanden, der sich auf einer DEFCON glaube ich das mal vorgeführt hat, hat einfach ein Gerät gebaut, was man zwischen diese Vigand Adern schaltet, was dann einfach mitschneidet, welche Karten funktionieren und dann beim Vorhalten einer bestimmten Karte einfach die alte Nummer wieder abspielt. Und so funktionieren tatsächlich auch die meisten Hobbyistenprojekte oder alles, was man so im Günstigen nicht. Wir sind jetzt ein Konzern und nehmen jetzt ein zehnmonatiges Projekt in Angriff, um alle unsere tausend Türen auszutauschen, sondern irgendwie so, wir haben eine Tür zu Hause oder wir sind ein Hackerspace mit drei Türen. All diese Projekte sind irgendwie ID basiert. Ich habe da auch eins gefunden, als ich mal danach gesucht habe, weil das war halt auch ja, es hat Vigand-Eingänge und ein paar Alarmeingänge und Türkontakte und ist dann halt wieder in die Kategorie Alban einzuordnen. Deswegen empfehle ich halt wirklich, wenn man wenn man so was haben will, muss man Deathfire nehmen. Also es gibt, wenn man so was günstig haben will, es gibt natürlich noch die teurere Variante, es gibt tatsächlich Java-Karten, die kontaktlos funktionieren. Da hat man also, es sieht genauso aus und funktioniert genauso. Man hält halt irgendwie so eine Plastikarte vor das Lesegerät und dann läuft aber auf der Karte nicht irgendein festverdrahtes Programm, sondern da ist Java drauf und das macht halt, was man will. Unter anderem eventuell auch gute Authentisierungsalgorithmen, wenn man es dann hingekriegt hat. Aber es ist halt teuer dann pro Karte. Dann liegt man halt nicht ein Euro oder zwei, sondern zehn oder fünfzehn auf den Tisch. Und das mögen viele Leute nicht. Und man muss erstmal das Java-Programm schreiben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da ist ja noch Folgekosten.
Genau. Deswegen würde ich tatsächlich, wenn mich jemand fragt zurzeit, Deathfire EV1 empfehlen. Da gibt es blöderweise einen großen Pferdefuß, Haken, was auch immer, wie man das formulieren möchte. NXP hat nämlich die Doku unter NDA, also Verschiegenheitserklärung. Ich kenne die Doku zwar, weil ich in der Firma damit arbeite, aber ich habe halt eine Verschiegenheitserklärung unterschrieben und kann jetzt nicht einfach irgendwas schreiben, was darauf basiert und das als Open Source weitergeben. Und es wird halt den meisten gehen, die irgendwie was damit zu tun haben. Aber ich habe mir das gerade mal angeguckt. Also du sagtest vorhin Hausautomatisierung, das gucke ich mir auch gerade so an und dann gab es so Foren. Und da hat auch jemand so was gebaut mit NFC und dann kommt eine Nummer raus und dann geht die Tür auf. Das fand ich dann, wie erwartet, war nicht so vollständig optimal, sagen wir mal, verbesserungswürdig oder mutig. Und habe mir dann überlegt, im Prinzip müsste man das mit Desfire bauen. Richtig. Gibt es aber alles noch nicht. Und dann ist mir aber aufgefallen, ich habe ein bisschen rumgegoogelt, es gibt tatsächlich jemanden, der schon mal eine Bibliothek geschrieben hat, der also entweder die NDA verletzt hat oder die Informationen irgendwo andersherr bekommen hat. Es gibt mittlerweile tatsächlich im Zusammenhang mit diesem Projekt, mit dem Touch Attack, also LibNFC heißt das Projekt, was den Touch Attack ansteuert, jemanden, der schon mal Desfire implementiert hat. Und ich gucke mir gerade mal an, ob man darauf basierend was basteln könnte, was dann auch im Niedrigpreisbereich bzw. als Open Source für so Karten funktionieren könnte. Denn der Punkt bei sowas ist ja dann, also was mir ja wichtig ist. Wir sind ja jetzt hier irgendwie bei der Sicherheit gewesen bei Tür geht auf, aber nur genau dann, wenn der Richtige davor steht. Noch schöner ist es ja, wenn man noch zum Beispiel hat, dass man nicht verfolgt werden kann. Ich habe gesagt, die Karten haben alle eine Seriennummer, die man immer abfragen kann. Die gehört nämlich zum Protokoll. Also My Fair Classic zum Beispiel kennt das gar nicht anders. Bei den neuen Desfire Karten kann man die Seriennummer oft zufällig stellen, also die benutzt im Protokoll. Und dann halt nur noch mit dem Schlüssel arbeiten. Und dann hat man halt eine Karte, wo ein Angreifer von außen nicht mehr erkennen kann, welche Karte das ist, selbst wenn er die gleiche Karte wieder sieht. Und auch nicht erkennen kann, zu welchem Schloss diese Karte gehört. Also irgendwie, jetzt wenn er keine Tauben mag und du eine Karte für deinen Taubenzüchterverein hast, kann er dir halt trotzdem nicht eins über die Rübe ziehen, weil er weiß, dass du zum Taubenzüchterverein gehörst.
Und das System weiß auch gleichzeitig nur, dass jemand drin ist, aber nicht wer drin ist.
Doch, das wäre dann... Ja, das überlege ich mir noch, ob ich das mal so in meiner Promotion vielleicht mal untersuche. Ja, das so hinzukriegen, das gibt es theoretisch auch. Das nennt sich Zero-Knowledge-Beweis. Man kann also tatsächlich etwas bauen, wo die prüfende Seite nur mitkriegt, dass derjenige, der den Beweis vorlegt, ein bestimmtes Geheimnis kennt, aber nicht das Geheimnis selber übermittelt. Oder nichts übermittelt, was auf das Geheimnisrückschlüssel zulassen würde. Du könntest also etwas bauen, das dafür sorgt. Gibt es tatsächlich auch als akademische Paper, da bräuchte man jetzt wieder Java-Karten für, weil man das erst implementieren muss. Also gibt es halt tatsächlich, dass man ganz viele Karten ausgibt. Auf allen ist ein Geheimnis drauf. Die Tür überprüft, ob derjenige, der die Karte vorlegt, ein Geheimnis hat, was in der gültigen Liste drin ist, damit man wieder Karten rausstreichen kann, weiß aber nicht, welcher von der Liste es war. Aber das ist dann aufwändige Mathematik mit ganz vielen hoch- und tiefergestellten Zahlen. Und dauert dann und ist aufwändig. Muss man erst mal bauen und darf man auch nicht falsch bauen. Und wenn jemand will was sagen.
Du musst dir das Wort einfach nehmen.
Aufwändige Elektronik oder aufwändige Mathematik bedeutet wieder, dass man lange rechnen muss, lange senden muss. Und gerade so ein System soll ja einfach sein und schnell zu montieren. Und wenn das in der Tür drin steckt und schnell zu montieren sein soll, hat das eine Akku. Und wenn man da lange senden muss und viel rechnen muss, dann ist die Akku schnell leer. Und das ist so ein großes Problem heute in der Praxis, ein sicheres System mit Verschlüsselung zu bauen, wo das Akku eine Weile hält.
Deswegen braucht man dafür einen Stromanschluss.
Und damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Na gut.
Das ist Schreit nach der dritten Sendung?
Nö, ich glaube, wir sind da jetzt.
Uns reicht es jetzt?
Ja, wir sind da relativ gut durch. Also was ich sagen wollte, man kann sowas bauen, baut in der Praxis keiner. Was man aber wirklich haben kann, ist etwas, wo die Tür nur ein Pseudonym mitkriegt. Also weiß, dass es irgendwie Kartennummer mit lange Zahl ist, aber diese Zahl nur an dieser einen Tür funktioniert. Und also dein Taubenzüchterverein und dein Dackelverein nicht die gleiche Zahl benutzen und sich nicht abstimmen können, zum Beispiel. Und ja, das kann man bauen. Und ich hoffe mal, dass man das auch bald haben kann.
Ich bin gespannt. Das war Chaosradio 186. Vielen Dank, Henrik. Vielen Dank, Simon. Und ich bin Holger Klein und danke euch für die Aufmerksamkeit. Das nächste Chaosradio, dann ist es vermutlich Folge 187. Wir werden das auch dann wieder demokratisch festlegen, welche Folgen das ist. Oder der Server ist wieder in Ordnung, kann ja auch sein, gibt es am letzten Dienstag im Februar. Und zum Abschied gibt es die Instrumentalversion von Kraftfutter Mischwerks am Wolkenberg. Aus einem einzigen Grund, mir ist nichts besseres eingefallen.
Ein Podcast von Fritz.